i'd like to start by thanking my friend
leila moran lelia you fought a
passionate campaign
full of energy and since becoming an mp
you've inspired so many people
particularly young people your future is
bright
and i look forward to you playing a big
role in my team
to members of the liberal democrats
thank you for putting your faith in me
and giving me the honor of leading a
party
i joined 30 years ago
and i also want to thank a whole host of
people who've run this campaign
whether in party headquarters alongside
the returning officer
or in my own campaign team
the thousands of people who volunteered
time to campaign with me
who've donated to my campaign who've
championed
our vision of a greener fairer
more caring country and i particularly
like to thank claire halliwell
my campaign manager claire you've been
fantastic and of course emily
my wife and our two beautiful children
john and ellie
thank you emily for your amazing support
patience
and love and i'm sure i'm speaking for
many people when i say that
for all the stress and uncertainty of
the last few months
one positive has been the chance to
spend more time with our families
and so i'd like to thank ellie in
particular
for appearing as a surprise cameo in so
many of my zoom calls
and hustings
i want to talk now about the future of
the liberal democrats
i joined this party 30 years ago i met
emily here
i've made so many good friends here
and with those friends i campaigned
across our country
knocking on tens of thousands of doors
delivering hundreds of thousands of
leaflets
the reason i have done all this is
simple
i love our party i believe in it
i stand for all the things liberal
democrats stand for
social justice political reform equality
and protecting our environment
i stand for fairness and for fighting to
protect the rights of
ordinary people and i'm determined
our party backs a britain that works
with other countries across the world
for peace and prosperity
but it is my love of our party
that makes me recognize that we must
change
we have to wake up and smell the coffee
nationally our party has lost touch with
too many voters
yes we are powerful advocates locally
our campaigners listen to local people
work hard for communities
and deliver results but at the
national level we have to face the facts
of three disappointing general election
results
the truth is voters don't believe
the liberal democrats want to help
ordinary people get on
in life voters don't believe we share
their values
and voters don't believe we are on the
side of people
like them nationally
voters have been sending us a message
but we have not been listening it is
time for
us to start listening
as leader i am telling you
i have got that message i am listening
now
so whether you're from the north south
or somewhere in between
whether you vote for brexit or remain or
just wanted the whole thing settled
whether you voted labor conservative
liberal democrat s p or applied
my message for you is this
i will travel up and down our country to
meet you
to hear about things that matter most to
you
your problems and fears your hopes and
dreams
i will face up to uncomfortable truths
and i will make your concerns my own
our country is going through one of the
most extraordinary and difficult periods
for generations the challenge of covid
will affect our country and the world
for decades to come
millions of people are suffering
as leader of the liberal democrats i
want to reach out to help you
and your community get through this
whether your concerns are your family's
health
your children's education or your
livelihood
and i want to understand the new future
you want after all this and help to
deliver it
so my job from today is to rebuild the
liberal democrats
to national relevance so we can deliver
this future for you
your family and for the people who need
it the most
none of this is going to be easy
none of this is going to be
straightforward
and none of it is going to be quick or
simple to achieve
but i want the liberal democrats to
represent the whole country not just
some people
and to stand for fairness and
opportunity for all
that is my commitment to you as the new
leader of the liberal democrats
the hard work starts today
thank you